[Music]
welcome to iowa where wind turbines rule
the land
and in the town of esterville there is a
wind program dishing out some of the
best wind technicians in the country
i'm joel caulfield and i'm here with my
dad jim caulfield we are students at
iowa lakes community college and we're
studying to be wind turbine technicians
[Music]
this is iowa lakes community college a
school that offers an intensive two-year
program in applied science in wind
turbine technology
jim and his son joel are students who
enter the program together
a wind technician is somebody who would
actually work on the wind turbine to
make sure that it is being serviced
properly and if it breaks down actually
be able to repair it you just basically
take a variations of different
electrical theory classes all the way up
to advanced level stuff of actual wiring
up circuits and advanced programming of
computers
wind turbine is actually big pieces of
equipment that carry a lot of risk and
that's why they are engraining in us
everything we need to know so that when
we're up there we know how to handle
every situation we can deal with
when you're going out to the turbine for
the first time you're very anxious and
nervous because you're going at a height
that you're never been to before
i mean there's a lot of fall potential
that could happen
to elaborate on what joel's saying it's
serious stuff that you don't take
lightly at all
when you get to the top you just start
to get more of an excitement over fear
and exhaustion because now you're up
there in the cell itself so it's
actually kind of cool to see a working
turbine in first action
for jim and joel going back to school
was a no-brainer jim left the trucking
industry after 26 years to follow his
passion in renewable energy and his son
joel wanted to travel the world and work
with his hands so enrolling in the win
program at the same time while
unconventional ended up working out
perfectly
we can bounce off each other for ideas
and stuff like that help each other with
like homework so it kind of gave us an
opportunity to grow better
there's a lot of things that i'm still
scratching my head on and you know he'll
just come by and it's like well you got
to do this and you've got to how do you
know that how do you know what he does
he gets it
it's actually a great feeling knowing
that i have a chance to
you know pursue a career in something
that i've been very passionate about
there are other people doing this and
it's worth it for anybody to go ahead
and make that next leap
[Music]